you know I was poor my parents they
always got a headache when we were you
know having you know family photos or
something like that because I always run
off and I was always hiding and they
always had to drag me there and I was
screaming and I never really want to be
a part of it and you know one one could
think that how I've had this all my life
and one would think in one would maybe
expect that I would be used to that by
now to be comfortable you know in front
of people or with photographers or
journalists asking you question but I'm
really not I'm I'm I think in the end of
the day I'm I'm quite shy and I don't
like being in the center of attention
but you know as as an official person as
I am I know that this is something I
have to deal with them and I'm I'm
struggling with it I'm working on it and
I'm here today